hey everyone i'm hannah wallock so in
today's webinar
miro dudek and i are going to tell you
all about fairness related harms
and ai systems so i'm going to spend the
first 30 minutes or so
explaining what fairness means in the
context of ai and machine learning
and giving you some examples of fairness
related harms
then i'm going to hand over to miro
who's going to dive deeper into
assessing
and mitigating two particular types of
fairness related harms
since most of you don't know me i wanted
to take a minute or so before i start to
tell you a little bit about who i am
and what i do so i'm a machine learning
researcher by training
and at this point i've been doing
machine learning for 20 years
working on a mix of theoretical and
applied projects
often in collaboration with social
scientists
over the past six years though most of
my research has been around
issues of fairness accountability
transparency
and ethics as they relate to ai and
machine learning
i'm a member of microsoft's fate
research group
which was formed in 2015 to focus on
exactly these issues
it's an inherently socio-technical group
with core
ai and machine learning researchers like
myself and miro
and researchers from human computer
interaction the social sciences
and even law
i'm also deeply involved in microsoft's
ether committee
ether stands for ai ethics and effects
in engineering and research and i
co-chair the ether working group on
fairness and inclusiveness
all right so with that let's get started
so at the risk of stating the obvious
we're living in the age of ai
machine learning is everywhere and at
least for the moment
it looks like it's probably here to stay
and in many ways this is awesome
but at the same time we're seeing that
the new opportunities brought about by
ai and machine learning
can also raise new challenges
particular challenges that have received
a lot of attention in the media
and have really highlighted how
important it is to get ai
right to make sure that ai does not
discriminate
or further disadvantage already
disadvantaged groups of people
some of these media stories have
involved high-stakes decisions
where ai systems are used to allocate
opportunities or resources
in ways that can have significant
negative impacts on people's lives
so for example i'm sure many of you
heard about the propublica investigation
a few years ago
which showed that compass a widely used
recidivism risk assessment tool
incorrectly scored black defendants has
high risk
more often than white defendants while
incorrectly scoring white defendants is
low risk
more often than black defendants
other stories have involved much more
mundane ai systems though
so for instance researchers at princeton
found that translating
he is a nurse and she is a doctor into
turkish
a genderless language and then back into
english
yields the stereotypical and in this
case incorrect
she is a nurse and he is a doctor
these stories are all examples of ai
systems behaving
unfairly but even though we can often
spot
fairness-related harms in ai systems
when we see them
there's no one-size-fits-all definition
of fairness
that applies to all ai systems in all
contexts
moreover fairness in ai is a
fundamentally socio-technical challenge
meaning that it cannot be approached
from purely social
or purely technical perspectives
taken together these factors can make it
a pretty daunting landscape to navigate
but although there are a few easy
answers there
are a variety of strategies emerging for
assessing and mitigating fairness
related harms
as well as a deepening understanding of
the challenge throughout society
and that's what miro and i will really
be focusing on today
so over the next 25 minutes or so i'm
going to give you a very high level and
definitely not comprehensive
overview of fairness related harms in ai
systems
i'm going to start by talking about some
of the main types of fairness related
harms that can occur
so that you'll know what to look out for
in your own systems
then i'm going to talk a little bit
about who might be affected by these
harms
so in other words which groups of people
might be most at risk of experiencing
them
next i'll briefly discuss how fairness
related harms can be introduced or
propagated
during the ai development and deployment
life cycle
and then i'll run through a few
strategies for assessing and mitigating
them
finally i'll conclude by telling you
where you can learn more about all of
this
and then i'll hand things over to miro
if you've read anything about fairness
in ai systems you've probably seen the
word
bias get thrown about left right and
center often as a catch-all way to
describe
any unfair behavior of any ai system
and any possible causes of that unfair
behavior
as well however in this webinar we're
going to avoid using the word bias
wherever possible and we recommend that
you do the same
this is because the word bias is
ambiguous and means
really different things to different
communities for example
statistical bias versus societal biases
instead we're going to talk about the
fairness related
impact that ai systems can have on
people
so specific types of fairness related
harms
and this level of precision is useful
for disentangling
who might be harmed by a system and in
what ways
as well as suggesting different
assessment and mitigation strategies
on that note i also want to emphasize
that because there are so many different
reasons
why ai systems can cause fairness
related harms
it's not really possible to fully
de-bias a system
or to guarantee its fairness and so
because of this we also don't recommend
using words like de-biasing or unbiased
which can set up really unrealistic
expectations
instead we recommend talking about and
assessing and mitigating fairness
related harms
as much as possible
all right so with that let's move on to
different types of fairness related
harms
broadly speaking there are five main
types of fairness related harms that can
be caused by an ai system
allocation quality of service
stereotyping
denigration and overall
under-representation
to explain each of these five types i'm
going to run through some illustrative
examples
starting with the most well-known type
allocation
but before i do that i want to note that
these types are not mutually exclusive
it's possible for a single ai system to
exhibit more than one type of harm
and in fact many of the examples that
i'm going to show you over the next few
slides
could have been used to illustrate one
or more of the other types of harms
as well
all right so first up allocation as i
said earlier many media stories have
focused on high-stakes decisions
where ai systems are used to allocate
opportunities or resources
in ways that can have significant
negative impacts on people's lives
so for example amazon abandoned its
automated hiring system
after finding that it amplified the
existing gender imbalance in the tech
industry
by withholding employment opportunities
from women
so next quality of service so quality of
service is all about whether a system
works as well for one person as it does
for another
even if no opportunities or resources
are extended or withheld
so for example researchers found that
three commercial gender classifiers had
higher error rates for images of women
with darker skin tones
than for images of men with lighter skin
tones
like accessibility issues quality of
service harms
can raise questions about respect and
dignity and personhood
so imagine how a user might feel if a
system repeatedly fails to recognize her
voice
but easily recognizes those of her peers
okay stereotyping so i briefly mentioned
stereotyping in the context of machine
translation earlier
but another well-known example is
latanya sweeney's work
where she showed that online
advertisements were more likely to
suggest that people with black sounding
names had been arrested
thereby reinforcing negative stereotypes
of black criminality
denigration is where an ai system is
itself part of a process that is
actively derogatory
demeaning or offensive so here for
example a few years ago google
photos infamously mislabeled an image of
black people as gorillas
this mislabeling is harmful not just
because the system made a mistake
but because it specifically applied a
label that has a long history of being
purposefully used
to denigrate and demean black people
and then finally over and under
representation
so these are fairly self-explanatory but
as a concrete example
researchers at the university of
washington found that for
professions with an equal or higher
percentage of men than women
such as engineering image search results
were even more heavily skewed toward
images of men
than reality
so then to recap the five main types of
fairness related harms that can be
caused by an ai system
are allocation quality of service
stereotyping denigration and
overall under representation i again
want to reiterate that these types are
not mutually exclusive
a single system can exhibit more than
one type of harm as i've indicated here
on this slide
and can even exhibit different harms for
different groups of people
too and finally fairness related harms
can have varying severities
so for instance unfairly denying someone
bail is a much more severe harm than
labeling an image of a female doctor as
a nurse
but it's important to remember that even
relatively non-severe harms
can make people feel alienated or
singled out
and their cumulative impact can be
extremely burdensome
all right so who is at risk of
experiencing fairness related harms
well sometimes it's for people who will
use or operate a system
but it can also be other stakeholders
who are directly or indirectly affected
by a system
either by choice or not
so for example in the case of a facial
recognition system for workplace
building access
the system operator is not the person
whose face is being recognized
and thus not the person who is most
immediately harmed if the system makes a
mistake
i also want to emphasize that although
media stories often focus on groups of
people that are protected by
anti-discrimination laws
such as groups defined in terms of race
gender
age or disability status there are
actually many different groups of people
that we want our systems to be fair with
respect to
and it's not always easy to identify the
most relevant ones
in part because they can even be
specific to the domain or the use case
so for example in the case of an
automated essay grading system
whether someone is a native speaker of
the language may actually be more
relevant than their age or their
disability status
it's also really important to remember
that groups intersect
and people within those intersections
may be at risk of experiencing unique
harms that might be obscured by
considering only non-intersected groups
so returning to the gender
classification example that i mentioned
earlier
error rates were significantly higher
for images of women with darker skin
tones
than for images of women overall or for
images of people with darker skin tones
overall
the researchers that conducted the study
were only able to uncover
these disparities by assessing system
performance
with respect to skin tone and binary
gender at the same time
okay so then why do ai systems cause
fairness related harms
well if you look at the way that ai
systems are portrayed by the media you
naturally assume that the only reason is
biased data sets
but in reality the situation is more
complex than that
not to mention the fact that the phrase
biased data sets
is often used to refer to data sets with
any number of undesirable
characteristics
such as reflecting stereotypes in their
content
or having too few data points about some
group of people
so over the next few slides i'm going to
run through some of the different
reasons
with examples so that you'll know what
to look out for
in your own systems
first though i want to explicitly
emphasize that although there are many
reasons why ai systems can behave
unfairly
these reasons seldom include bad
intentions on the part of the teams
responsible
for developing or deploying those
systems
okay so then starting with data sets
some ai systems behave unfairly because
of societal biases
that are reflected in the content of the
data sets used to train them
so returning to amazon's automated
hiring system
the system withheld employment
opportunities from women
because the data with which it had been
trained reflected the existing gender
imbalance
in the tech industry
as another example people express
societal biases via the language they
use
so for instance gender occupation
stereotyping
might lead people to say she is a nurse
and he is a doctor these societal biases
are then necessarily reflected
in the content of large-scale language
data sets
like the ones used to train machine
translation systems
as a third example there's a lot of
research showing that societal biases
often come into play
when labeling data developing clear
labeling guidelines that reduce the
likelihood that labelers will need to
make judgment calls or other subjective
decisions
can really help in this regard
other ai systems behave unfairly not
because of societal biases that are
inherent to the data sets used to train
them
but because of other data set
characteristics like too few data points
about some group of people
so for instance the reason why the three
gender classifiers that i mentioned
earlier
had higher error rates for images of
women with darker skin tones
was because there weren't enough images
of women with darker skin tones in the
data sets used to train them
in some cases the relative proportions
of different groups of people
in a data set may even reflect reality
but the sampling strategy can still lead
to insufficient data
about some groups especially those that
are much smaller
so turning now to characteristics of
other system components
even the structure of a machine learning
model can cause the system to behave
unfairly
so in this toy example here on the
screen in which people are represented
by
two features one on the x-axis and one
on the y-axis
the majority group and the minority
group look fundamentally different to
each other in terms of those
features as a result there's no single
linear classifier
that works well for both we can even
extrapolate from this toy example to a
real world scenario
so facial recognition system for airport
security screening
that relies on a single match threshold
might result in different error rates
for different groups of people
with some people experiencing especially
high error rates
one way of addressing this might be to
design the system to use a set of match
thresholds
that can be dynamically selected based
on operating conditions
in turn allowing for more consistent
error rates across
different groups
as another example ai systems can even
behave unfairly because of their
objective functions
so here i'm showing image search results
for the term boy
on the left and the term girl on the
right and these clearly look very
different to each other
this probably comes from the fact that
search engines optimize for clicks among
other metrics
this example shows just how hard it can
be to address fairness related harms
in different circumstances the term girl
may be
referring to a child or a woman and use
a search for this term with very
different intentions
in this case for reasons you can imagine
one of these intentions may be more
prevalent
than the other
and finally some ai systems behave
unfairly because of assumptions made
during the ai development and deployment
life cycle
including assumptions about what ai can
and cannot do
as an extreme example of what can go
wrong here
in 2016 a paper came out by a group of
researchers who propose
training a facial analysis system to
predict who is going to commit a crime
based on images of people's faces this
is extremely worrying for a whole host
of reasons
and could lead to substantial harms for
people who are misclassified
i hope it goes without saying that even
with good intentions
this is a questionable system purpose
and not something that ai is actually
capable of doing
as another example sometimes ai systems
behave unfairly because of assumptions
about what a particular data set
captures and how this relates to the
system purpose
so for instance a crime prediction
system trained on arrest
on an arrest data set relies on the
assumption that the number of arrests in
a neighborhood
is a good proxy for the amount of crime
committed there
but this assumption fails to account for
higher rates of arrest without
conviction
or for over policing in less affluent
neighborhoods
so the resulting system may make
inaccurate predictions that reflect
historical policing practices
rather than the occurrence of crime
itself
there are also more subtle examples too
so consider gender classification
so predicting someone's gender from a
photo
on the surface it might be less obvious
how assumptions can lead to
fairness-related harms here
but there are a couple of reasons so one
is that if a gender classifier only
predicts binary genders
it won't work at all for people whose
gender is non-binary
gender classification also reinforces
societal stereotypes
a type of assumption about how people of
different genders are supposed to
look in fact the way gender classifiers
work is by leveraging gender stereotypes
which means that they therefore only
work well for people whose appearance
matches those stereotypes
so to learn more about making and
testing assumptions and how these
activities can either cause or prevent
fairness related harms you can check out
this paper on measurement and fairness
by abigail jacobs and myself which
appeared at this week's fact conference
so the examples that i just showed you
are by no means comprehensive but i hope
they've convinced you that there are
many reasons why ai systems behave
unfairly
to recap sometimes some ai systems
behave unfairly because of societal
biases that are reflected in the data
sets used to train them
or because of other data set
characteristics like too few data points
about some group of people
other times though it's because of
system characteristics like
model structures that are too simple to
capture the diversity of the real world
or objective functions with unintended
consequences
and sometimes it's simply because of
assumptions or decisions
made by teams either explicitly or
implicitly
throughout the ai development and
deployment life cycle
because there are so many reasons and
because these reasons are not mutually
exclusive and tend to exacerbate one
another
assessing and mitigating fairness
related harms are not things that can be
treated as an afterthought
they have to be prioritized at every
single stage
of the life cycle and in fact
if you only take one thing away from
this talk today
i kind of hope it's that
okay so what are some strategies for
assessing fairness related harms
well first it's necessary to decide what
it means for an ai system
or any ai system in question to behave
fairly
as i said before though there's no
one-size-fits-all
definition of fairness that applies to
all ai systems in all contexts
but for example a facial recognition
system should not
exhibit substantial differences in error
rates between
groups defined in terms of skin tone
gender and age
while a machine translation system
should not propagate
gender stereotypes although it can be
really hard to specify
concrete fairness criteria especially
for harms like stereotyping and
denigration
assessing fairness criteria throughout
the development and deployment life
cycle
makes it much easier to tell if harms
have been introduced
or even reintroduced as a project
evolves
if you decide to use quantitative
fairness metrics that operationalize
allocation or quality of service harms
as your fairness criteria then you can
use the open source fair learn
toolkit to assess and explore trade-offs
between different metrics
and even mitigate unfairness according
to those metrics
if you want to use fair learn yourself
it's available on github
and it's integrated into azure ml and of
course miro will be doing a much deeper
dive into the math behind fair learn
in a minute
it's also really important to undertake
extensive user testing with diverse
stakeholders
documenting the results broken down by
different stakeholder groups
including demographic groups and
documenting any implications
of those results this kind of user
testing should be done
even if a system meets the specified
fairness criteria
because it might exhibit unanticipated
fairness related harms
that the criteria just don't capture
on that same note it's generally a good
idea to put in place processes and
mechanisms
for receiving and responding to
stakeholder feedback
including user complaints and concerns
it's also worth inviting independent
parties to audit or evaluate ai systems
and in fact it was this kind of an
evaluation that revealed the three
commercial gender classifiers
differences
in error rates
okay so then what about mitigating
fairness related harms
well this is a really big topic and
there's enough material for entire talk
in and of itself so i'm only going to
talk very briefly about this
most importantly though i want to
emphasize that there's no silver bullet
or uber tool
that will magically fix all fairness
related harms in
any ai system therefore
ultimately the most important thing you
can do
is learn about fairness related harms so
exactly what you're doing right now
so that you can then anticipate the most
common causes of them
and try to avoid them as much as
possible
my collaborators and i have actually
created a fairness checklist to help
teams do this
you can find the checklist in the
accompanying academic paper online
and we're currently looking for teams to
partner with us on customizing and using
the checklist in different domains
for different use cases and with
different workflows
so if you're interested in partnering
with us please do reach out to me via
email
of course even with something like our
fairness checklist it's still
possible to overlook things and this is
why it's so important to specify and
assess
fairness criteria if the fairness
criteria reveal
evidence of fairness related harms a
good starting point is to revisit
all assumptions and system components
including data sets
there are even some software tools that
can help you understand or mitigate
particular types of fairness related
harms like the fair learn toolkit that i
mentioned before
and like microsoft's open source debug
ml toolkit which was released in
february
and which i'm showing here on this slide
of course as i said earlier it's not
really possible to fully de-bias an ai
system
or to guarantee its fairness and when
deployed in the real world even a
well-developed and thoroughly tested
system can still cause fairness-related
harms for this reason it's important to
be transparent about the characteristics
and limitations of ai systems
including any limitations revealed by
fairness criteria
or user testing one way to do this is to
create data sheets and model cards
for the data sets and models that
compose a system
as well as transparency notes or fact
sheets for systems as a whole
and you can find a template for creating
data sheets for data sets
on microsoft's responsible ai resource
center
so last but not least where can you
learn more
first as i just mentioned there's
microsoft's responsible ai resource
center
which contains links to a number of
different resources
including the fairness checklist that i
mentioned earlier the fair loan toolkit
and the template for creating data
sheets for data sets
there are also a lot of fairness related
resources on the fate
research group website so here you can
find information about the members of
the fate research group
as well as our academic publications and
other papers
career opportunities and some of our
incubation projects as well
all right so with that i'm going to stop
and hand over to miro
to tell you more about assessing and
mitigating fairness related harms
but please feel free to get in touch
with me via email
if you have any questions thank you
thanks hannah i'll now dive deeper into
how to assess and mitigate
fairness related issues my name is miro
dudig and
i'm a machine learning researcher at
microsoft research new york
i'm also a co-creator of fairlearn which
is an open source python toolkit
it started out at msr but since then it
has expanded to be
a community driven project and our goals
with fair learn
is to um is to enable data scientists to
do
assessment and mitigation of fairness
issues in a their ai systems
and so uh that talk and that is my
portion of the talk will be focusing on
the conceptual
issues that underlie fair learn and at
the end of the talk i will give you some
pointers of where exactly
within the failure and toolkit you can
find them
so as a reminder by unfairness
we mean negative impacts for groups of
people such as those defined
in terms of race gender age or
disability status throughout my talk
i'll be focusing on two running examples
the first example is a system for
screening loan applications
such a system might be much better at
picking good candidates
say among white men than among other
groups and this is an example
of an allocational harm since as a
result
some resources in this case loans are
withheld
from certain applicants the second
example that i'll be using
is a speech-to-text transcription system
which might fail to work as well for
women as it does for men
and this is an example of a quality of
service harm in other words the system
does not work as well
for some groups of people to invest for
others
now we will be focusing on the
assessment of fairness in other words
we will try to answer the question about
which groups are negatively impacted and
by how much
and then we will think about
different approaches for mitigating
unfairness and
we'll be looking at approaches that are
purely algorithmic which means
they work without collecting any more
data
and these two steps are this
this talk uh falls into the ai life
cycle that hannah mentioned that like
just like at a couple of its stages so
the assessment of fairness
relates to the mall evaluation stage and
mall
monitoring stage but of course when
we're thinking
about how to assess these harms
and when and what level of unfairness
we might allow in in our system release
like we're also thinking about model
requirements
when we're talking about algorithmic
mitigation that one relates to the mall
training pipeline the model training
stage of the ai
life cycle and
in particular please keep in mind that
uh that
it is possible to mitigate unfairness
also at every other stage
so so our our treatment of mitigation in
this stock
will be will be fairly narrow
so now let's dive deeper into our first
example which is the screening of loan
applications
in this case we are considering
a screening algorithm that takes as
an input loan applications
and then triages them decides which of
them
should be accepted and passed on further
to the loan officer
or underwriter or they should be
rejected the in this case
the machine learning tasks is formally a
binary classification
given the input data which is the
the application and we need to decide
whether to reject that corresponds to
the negative label label equals zero
or to accept this corresponds to the
positive label label one
the way that the systems are trained
using supervised learning approaches
that were
typically have have a data set that
includes a set of
applicants that applied for loans in the
past each of them is described by a
feature vector
that essentially describes their loan
appropriation
and then we have a label that
corresponds to whether
this applicant defaulted on loan this is
the negative label
or did not default in other words repaid
the loan or was paying it on time
which would be the positive label now
when we are training such a system we
would like to come up with a
classification rule that would typically
optimize the
the cost for the bank and one thing to
keep in mind is that even though we're
looking at binary classification
we don't want to be thinking about just
the standard
misclassification error and this is
because the
the different kinds of errors bear
different kinds of costs
in this context we have two kinds of
error
one error kind of error is a false
positive this is when we decide to
accept an applicant that eventually
defaults
and this and these kinds of errors
contributed
to the default risk for the bank and
these events are associated with
costs uh that are related to a
collecting
a debt the second kind of an error
is the the false negative and uh this
happens when the bank rejects an
applicant that would have
been able to repay the loan and this is
obviously a loss of
profit a loss of a customer
and so uh if we are not thinking about
the fairness yet and just purely think
about this problem from the perspective
of the
bank the goal is to learn a classifier
which is a rule that takes as an input
an application and then decides whether
to
accept or reject and we're looking for a
classifier that
minimizes this this cost function
now how we might go about doing a
fairness assessment for this
let me walk you through the steps
the first step of a fairness assessment
is to identify the harms and possibly
also benefits
that this service creates among
its customers the second step will be
identified
what are the groups that are most likely
to be affected by these harms and then
finally based on that define
a fairness metric so
what are the harms and the benefits
associated
with the lending it turns out that from
the perspective of customers
it's uh we need to be here we can be
considering similar kinds of
adverse events as we're considering from
the perspective of the bank
however their costs and their
interpretation might be a little bit
different
when again we're thinking about false
negatives
this is when an applicant that would be
capable of repaying loan
is rejected uh this is an adverse event
because
the resources the loans are in this case
withheld from qualified applicants
uh the second kind of an error defaults
positive means that an applicant does
get the loan
but eventually defaults and so as a
result
the now now the applicant will be sent
to the debt collection agencies and
their credit might be impacted as well
as their ability to lend
in to uh to borrow uh in future
and so uh so we are not the
so these uh two kinds of events um
might uh bear cost to two individual
candidates
uh the individual applicants that are
different from those
from the perspective of the bank and so
typically we'll want to track them
separately sometimes this cost might not
be known to us
so we'll be focusing on both of these
events separately from the perspective
of the of the loan applicants okay so
now that we have defined
the identified the harms uh the next
step is to identify the groups
that might be affected
when it um when it comes to to landing
for example in as recently as in 2019 it
was uh reported
that um that women were receiving much
lower
credit limits by by the apple card
compared with their spouses uh who had
with whom they us
they shared assets as well as accounts
and so
definitely at least like one instance
that we should be looking
out for is the groups that are defined
by uh by gender identity
and another another example to consider
uh are our groups uh based on race
and that this is because in the us there
is a long history
of racial disparities in access to
credit
now besides uh gender identity
and race uh when when looked at uh
individually uh we should be also
thinking about
their intersections and this is
something that also hannah mentioned
in her part of the talk and very often
we've we see that the harms are
exacerbated for uh
for the individuals that are at the
intersection
of uh of multiple historically
marginalized groups
and in this case uh for example black uh
black women uh might be uh more likely
to experience
the harms related to landing
now okay so so we talked about gender
identity we talked about race
you might wonder where do i stop like
are there some groups said that
i might have forgotten and
in the case of lending actually we can
look
at um at the legal environment we can
look at the u.s
law and there is uh in the
one of one of the laws that regulate
lending equal credit opportunity act
actually does list uh a set of uh
factors uh that um that lenders
are required to um to to consider when
uh uh when thinking about um
discrimination
so in this case they the the these
factors are race
color religion national origin sex
marital status as well as age
now what i would like to point out is
that the law
is concerned with discrimination now
discrimination is related
and definitely intertwined with the
questions of fairness
but uh but but some of the tools the way
we deal with
these concerns are a little bit
different and uh and i might i might
circle back to this
later on in the talk but uh but uh
but in this case uh we can we are using
the law
as an inspiration to decide what are the
groups that we should be thinking about
but uh but implementing fairness of ai
systems
or mitigating unfairness does not
necessarily is not necessarily the same
as thinking about discrimination or
anti-discrimination okay
but in this case at least we can use the
law to uh to come up with a good
starting point of what this group should
be
so we have talked about the first two
steps
about identifying the harms where we
talked about the false positives and
false negatives
and then the step of identifying the
affected groups
and for simplicity in the rest of this
example i'll be focusing
on the groups this uh based on gender
and so so that this would be women men
and non-binary people
now with these groups and
harms uh the question we are ready now
to uh to look at what the fairness
metrics might be for our application
now remember that our goal here is to
ensure
that uh that none of the groups
are are
are affected more than others by these
harms
and so in order for us to to be able to
answer that question
we often form uh a table of
disaggregated metrics well what do i
mean by this
this is simply a table where each matrix
corresponds to different column
so when we're looking at the false
positive harm we could measure
how prevalent it is by by looking at a
false positive rate
within each slice of the data
corresponding to different groups
so we can see that the women experience
37 percent false positive rate
uh men 31 percent and non-binary people
and we have a column like this for for
each of the different metrics
that quantify different kinds of harms
that we're considering
so so in this case we were talking about
false positive rate to quantify the
false positive
the harms associated with false
positives and false negative rate
to quantify the harms associated with
false negatives
examining this table we see that that
the women see the largest false positive
rate
and the men see the smallest and so it's
and 31 and and we have a flip situation
where it comes to false negatives
where where women have the smallest at
the level of 27 percent
and men largest at the 35 okay
there is one other thing that we can
tell from the table which is that uh
that non-binary people have a much much
smaller count in this in this data
what this means is that when we're
looking at a false positive rate and
false negative rate
uh we need to to be a little bit more
careful how we implement
interpret these numbers in particular uh
we have less certainty about whether how
true the
how close to the to the ground through
these values might be in other words we
have larger error bars
okay so in this case we have
three groups and two metrics so perhaps
when we are thinking about
how our system affects our
our group of customers or our group of
loan applicants this might be sufficient
however
when we have a larger number of groups
or want to define
some some criteria of whether how
fair our system is uh we might want to
distill this to
um to to to a smaller set of summaries
and to do that
we uh we can we can define the two kinds
of fairness metrics
that look at at how
how disparate the values of these
metrics are
across the groups for example when we're
looking at a false positive rate
uh we can we can consider the difference
between the largest and smallest
smallest value and the report reported
as a as a as a measure of as one of them
measures of fairness here
in this case would be a 0.06 similarly
we can look at the false negative rate
and again report the difference between
the largest and smallest value
instead of focusing on the largest
difference we can also be
looking at the ratio and and here we
make a convention that we take the ratio
between the smallest and the largest
number
this means that the ratio is always
smaller than one
and ratio of one corresponds to the
situation when
when all of the metric values are are
equal so so in other words there is no
disparity
and with respect to that metric across
our groups okay so
so for the ratio we want to be as close
to one for difference we want to be as
close to zero
now uh when we're deciding whether to
release
an existing system whether to release a
model uh then the question of course of
course arises
is this difference that we see here 0.06
and 0.08
too large and similarly for the ratio
in other words that how do i know
whether
my model is sufficiently fair to be
released
now there are there is no
easy and universal answer to this
and so so in some sense this
will typically be context specific what
is
important is to be very explicit
about the priorities that we're using to
decide
which whether it is acceptable or no and
in particular
sometimes you might be considering
multiple different models
that exhibit different values of
different fairness and performance
metrics
and so so we need to then in that case
prioritize and
such once we come up with a transparent
set of priorities
at that point we we end up working often
with assessment
reports that list performance metrics as
as well as these these disaggregated
metrics of
of harms to different subgroups uh as
well as
some of this difference and ratio uh
metrics corresponding uh to uh
to extend uh that quantify the
disparities
and um and we're using these um these
assessment reports
uh to uh to verify that our priorities
are are indeed being uh being satisfied
that we're following our priorities
i would like to make one important point
however
so i i've been talking about the fact
that you know that uh
that sometimes we might be in a
situation where we might prioritize
um fairness relative to performance
perhaps
now uh while while we might be in that
situation sometimes
over a large set of benchmark data sets
where we're trying to um
to to apply uh um
some of the mitigation techniques we
have found that this might be a false
dichotomy
and very often it is possible to uh
to to mitigate the unfairness quite
substantially
uh without seeing a large um
much of a sacrifice in performance and
so so there might not even be much of a
trade-off
between fairness and performance now
even in those situations
when the fairness assessment suggests
some kind of a trade-off
between fairness and performance uh it
turns out that
our assessment card or our assessment
report might
not be a fully accurate prediction of
future performance
for example imagine that you're
developing a service like
such as the service that we'll be
talking about in a moment the
speech-to-text service
and uh during uh and during the initial
analysis you see
it seems that there is some kind of a
trade-off you decide to roll out the
service
that perhaps seemingly such a sacrifice
on performance but
but is more fair and what might happen
is that you might be able to attract
the customers that were previously
underserved and that that uh
that growth in in the customer base will
more than compensate
for for any of the the performance drop
that you might have predicted otherwise
in other words uh by changing the
product
you are you're in a way making the
historic data less representative
of the future data that your product
will continue to generate
so um so let me so now we have
wrapped up talking about uh about our
first example which was
which was the the landing scenario let
me now jump
into the second example and we will try
to go again through the steps
of fairness assessment but in this case
we will be able to go a little bit
faster
because because we'll essentially just
kind of follow the similar stages
as we did for the landing scenario
so the this in speech to text
application we are trying uh
to to design a transcription algorithm
which takes
as an input speech provided in some kind
of a
waveform and tries to transform it uh
transcribe it into text for example
you might be consuming this webinar
using
such a service to to obtain either
transcription or closed captioning
now formally this machine learning task
compared with with our prior tasks which
was just binary classification
it seems more complicated it is the task
of structured prediction
remember we're trying to transcribe a
waveform recording into words
however the data still looks like it
still does supervise learning data in
other words
we do have we do have n pairing of of
inputs and
outputs in this case input is the
waveform recording and output
is the matching sequence of words
ignoring any fairness issue the machine
learning task is still
to to learn a trust transcription rule a
transcription function that minimizes
the performance metric
which in our case here is is the word
error rate
so what's the word error rate the word
error rate counts three different kinds
of errors
uh these are substitution errors when
the transcription system
uh picks an incorrect word instead of
some kind of um
a ground truth or it deletes some of the
word or it inserts the word that wasn't
there
and that the number of these errors is
divided by the total number of words
that were spoken
now uh the if the system is perfect of
course they'll make no errors and
achieve the word error rate of
zero if the system makes around
one error one error per word then it
will achieve the word error rate of one
but if but it's possible to make even
more than one error per word
in which case the the value of the word
can be even larger than one
so goal here is to learn a predictor
that minimizes such an average error
rate
okay so this is our basic machine
learning task
now let's uh think through again the
steps of how to do fairness assessment
for for this task the first step
just as before is to identify the harms
now before we're looking at an
allocation scenario so
so in a way the uh the interest and
benefit of the bank were a little bit
different from the benefits of the
customers even though we're looking at
the
at the similar kinds of adverse events
they would have been weighted
differently
and then in quality of service scenarios
however
uh typically benefit of the user uh
tends to be measured quite well by the
underlying performance metric
in which case uh so this is this word
error rate
and so the word error rate works quite
well
here to quote to quantify the underlying
arms
now the second step is to identify the
affected groups and in the specific
case there was a recent study
from stanford that was reported on then
in new york times that pointed out
that speech recognition systems
have show very large disparities
across racial groups in particular black
americans were receiving substantially
higher error rates
than other groups uh
again the question arises about uh what
other factors we should consider when
thinking about
groups and unlike the the landing
scenario
and this scenario we that we do not
necessarily have
access to uh to the laws that would be
regulating this uh this domain
but that we can still reach out to uh to
experts on
speech on unfairness in speech on
inclusive design
even we can engage with sociolinguists
to uh to land on the
on the factors that uh um that
they're relevant in this application
so let me show you what is the set of
factors that they will believe makes
sense uh
in in this setting so the factors fall
into the three different groups here
uh the the first group uh it turns out
to be applicable in many other quality
of service scenarios as well
and these are standard demographic
factors that we also saw
in the in the lone scenario so this
would be
categories around race gender identity
and
age in addition to to these categories
there are we we often consider a variety
of service specific scenarios that will
be different
for each of the quality of service
setting for example
in the in the speech to text there is um
one of such characteristics is whether
the
person is a native or non-native speaker
so for example uh folks like me who do
not have
a native accent uh will might might
face uh harsher harms or might might see
larger errors
as well as folks with a variety of
regional dialects
and besides these characteristics we can
of course think about intersections
now that we have defined the
the harms uh quantified by the word
error rate
and we have defined also the set of uh
demographic groups the final step is to
define fairness metrics
now we begin with again our
disaggregated metrics which is in this
case just the word
error rate evaluated on different slices
here i'm showing
the table that corresponds to slices
defined by uh
by raise and again we can look at what
is the difference between
the the best and the worst performance
or what is the ratio between the two
again remember that that the difference
we want it to be close to zero
and ratio we would like it to be to be
close to one okay
so so in this case this appears to be
actually like a quite
quite a large uh quite a large disparity
however in a quality of service settings
there is there is one more meaningful
fairness metric that we could consider
which is the
the worst case performance across all
possible groups
so so in this example that i'm showing
you here
uh this is the since the
the word aerate the larger the worst
performance
uh the the worst case performance
corresponds to to the 0.28
and in practice before we release a
product
we might consider like all three of
these metrics and for example would like
to assure
that there is not a large disparity and
each of the groups gets at least certain
uh minimum performance that corresponds
to uh
to a good quality of service so now we
have walked
a little bit faster through our second
center so let me summarize
how what are the what are the important
aspects of fairness assessment
we looked at two scenarios the first one
was the landing scenario
which in which case
we there was a risk of allocation harms
in such scenarios our goal
is to allocate resources opportunities
in a manner
that would minimize the disparities in
outcomes and this typically
is applied in the in the domains in
various kind of high stakes domains such
as
lending or hiring
school admissions our second example
was that of a quality of service
where we were looking at the
speech-to-text
transcription system and there the goal
is to provide a similar quality of
service
across the demographic groups including
the marginalized groups
when we're doing the fairness assessment
our workhorse
were the disaggregated metrics that were
designed to measure harm
or benefit for each of the identified
groups
now in certain settings we would need to
summarize this metric so that we could
decide
uh whether uh the whether we're for
example able to release a product
or even maybe for diagnostic purposes we
wanted to check
where we need to dig deeper and examine
some of the issues further
and uh so for these purposes we defined
three kinds of
fairness metrics one of them was the the
worst case
performance across groups and the other
two were the ratio
and difference between the best uh and
the worst performance
or the best uh and the worst uh value
of uh of the metric now in order for us
to be able to conduct such an assessment
we need
a test data set where uh where we have
information
about the membership of individuals in
these
identified demographic groups besides
that we also need to have of course
access to the system output and the
ground truth
um for for each of the examples
now let me point out a couple of caveats
of of conducting a fairness assessment
first it is important to realize that
the data set characteristics
will influence the quality of the
fairness assessment
for example if you do not have enough
data from one of the affected groups
you will be much less confident in
quantifying the harms or
benefits that are accrued to that group
now going beyond just the question of uh
of whether i have enough data or no uh
there is uh
even if you have enough data uh the
issue might be that the data reflects
existing societal biases
uh for example uh any historic data from
school admissions or hiring or lending
is likely
to reflect some some historical societal
biases
and so uh so it's important to be aware
of these biases and and to the extent
that they correspond to statistical bias
some of them can then be corrected uh
for during the the statistical
estimation phase just just using
standard statistical estimators for for
these settings
besides data set characteristics uh the
we should also pay close the close
attention
to how we define the labels
in particular we should be concerned
with situation when labels might not be
good match
for quantifying the outcomes that we
actually care about
for example we might be interested in
assessing the healthcare needs of our
patients
and some of the past work was looking at
the uh
at the at the healthcare costs in
historical records as a proxy
for healthcare needs but uh but it turns
out
that that this is uh this is not quite
the right way to approach this
because the the people that have access
to to more resources
that the people that that are uh
wealthier are more likely
uh to um to to use uh
higher healthcare costs even if their
amount of healthcare needs is the same
as for folks uh that might not be as
wealthy
the final point to keep in mind is that
the choice of fairness metric is highly
context dependent the
there are two two parts to this so so
first off when designing the metric
itself uh we should think about
carefully uh how to measure
harm in that context the second part is
how we should be comparing the metric
values
across the different subgroups for
example we
saw we saw that in the lending scenario
it was meaningful uh to to
to to to uh to look for um
for models where the differences between
between the adverse occurrence of
adverse events is small
on the other hand in some of the quality
of service scenarios we might instead
be interested in the worst case
performance
and in particular making sure that our
worst case performance
reaches at least a certain amount of
quality
so i have told you how to do fairness
assessment then
maybe you you followed some of uh
some of these approaches to to check how
[Music]
how your ai system works and you found
out that it is unfair according to your
firm
fairness metrics so what can you do next
in the rest of the talk we'll look at
some of the mitigation
strategies for fairness related harms
and in particular we will be focusing
on algorithmic unfairness mitigation
strategies
because this is something you can try
before you collect more data
or before you design new features and i
suggest that you try these approaches
even if your systems
uh look reasonably fair because you
might be able
to uh to to to decrease
any any remaining unfairness without
necessarily sacrificing much of the
system performance
now one thing to to keep in mind here is
that
that that in regulated domains uh you um
you should be careful uh applying these
mitigation strategies in particular
the applicability or suitability of any
of the mitigation strategies needs to be
considered in the context
of the domain in particular the law
might
prevent you from using certain
certain sensitive features at the
deployment time
so with this caveat let's take a look at
two
mitigation approaches that are and i'll
be using
the same two examples um as i was using
earlier in the talk
the first approach is called
post-processing
and this one is particularly suitable
for the binary classification
such as uh the the application to
landing as we
as as we saw in in the in the talk
earlier
and in this case um as the
as the name says we're looking at a way
to post-process an existing model
to to obtain a model that is that is
more fair that mitigates some of the
fairness issues
as an input to this method we take an
existing
scoring model this is a model uh for
example in the landing scenario it would
take as an input
the loan application and would return a
real
value a real number that predicts the
probability of repaying the loan
in addition to such a trained model we
would also need a data set
that includes both the field of
applications
as well as the the ground through
whether the person defaulted or no
and as well as the as the group
membership information
for example if we're thinking about
about mitigating unfairness along um
along the different gender identity
groups we would need to know um
whether uh whether the individuals were
women male or non-binary people
now the approach itself is seeking to
to threshold scores in a way that would
be group dependent in order to achieve
better fairness metrics more formally
the goal
is for each group to find a threshold
above which we will essentially accept
the applicants you know so certain
threshold for the probability of
repaying the loan
above which will be accepting the
applicants and we're trying to find
thresholds that optimize the overall
performance metric
subject to fairness constraints so the
overall performance is cost to the bank
the the fairness constraints in this
case remember
are measure the fairness in this case is
is measured by by false positive rate
and false negative rate
and so the form of fairness constraints
uh um
would require uh that the false positive
rates
are the same across all groups and false
negative rates
should also be the same across all
groups
let me now measure a couple of
advantages and disadvantages of
post-processing
perhaps the most obvious advantage is
its conceptual simplicity
it is quite the natural and it is
perhaps something that
the institutions are already doing this
notion of thresholding
based on the based on the probability of
repayment
also the ability to use existing scoring
model is um
is is a very convenient feature now when
it comes to disadvantages uh there
there is an obvious one which i
mentioned uh also uh
on the previous slide which is uh that
the post processing requires access to a
sensitive feature at the test time
and this is something that might not be
practical to achieve in practice
perhaps this is something we might not
be able to to collect at the deployment
time
in other settings it might not be even
legal for example
you know i i was i was giving an example
uh where uh of lending and
gender identity it turns out that this
would not be possible
under the existing uh law in the us
however under american law it would be
possible to for example
have the different rules that take into
account age
in a very very narrow context now the
second
disadvantage is that the fairness
constraints must be
expressed as equal rates and
uh the so so as a result so i i gave you
an example saying that the false
positive raise and true positive rates
uh must be uh the the same
what this means is that that our our
model
does not allow trade-offs between
uh fairness and and performance so in
some sense since we're insisting
on on perfectly match satisfying the
fairness constraints
uh in certain situations that this might
lead to dramatic
decrease in performance and and we do
not have any opportunity to tweak this
and the final limitation is that this is
limited to binary classification
now uh let me now now
looks like i gave you these
disadvantages and in
the and maybe it's a it's a good setup
for for describing
the the second approach which actually
addresses all three of them
while while imposing uh some amount of
the computational overhead so so the
approach itself
is isn't perhaps not as simple as the
post processing
so the the second approach i'll be
talking about is a reductions approach
and this is something
that was developed at microsoft research
by by several folks including myself
and hannah the way that this approach
works is
it takes an existing standard machine
learning algorithm
and treats it as a black box and then
turns it
into a machine learning algorithm that
does not merely
optimize performance but about optimizes
performance as subject
to uh to fairness constraints uh just as
before
at the training time we do need to have
access to data sets
that include group membership
information
so how does this approach manage to do
this you know
you give it a standard algorithm and we
somehow turn it into an algorithm
that optimizes not just fairness but
fairness subject and
the optimize is not just performance but
performance subject to fairness
constraints
the way that this approach works is that
it starts off
by training um the model
on the on its initial input data
ignoring the sensitive features
and then checks whether the fairness
constraints are violated
if they are violated it re-weighs the
data in a specific fashion and sends
back to the standard learning algorithm
and iterates now the re-weighting step
because i as i mentioned it involves
checking whether
the the fairness constraints are
satisfied so this rewaiting step
does use sensitive features but
but the retraining step is relying only
on the standard machine learning
algorithm and so it does not
use this sensitive features also because
we are we're just looking at the we're
just
aggregating results from these models
returned by the standard
machine learning algorithm the final mod
that we return
does not require access to sensitive
features either
and
this this means uh that this approach is
quite highly modular uh for example you
can take an
existing algorithm that you have
previously used to train your system so
something
that you have high that you have tuned
for which you have designed features
that work very well
and and and now you would like to
incorporate fairness constraints so you
can use the exactly same algorithm
and combine with reduction approach to
now obtain
a model that besides optimizing
performance or
also satisfies the care fairness
constraints okay so i've been talking
about
uh performance metric and fairness
constraints so as a reminder let me make
this a little bit more concrete
and again i'll be instantiating on the
examples
that that we had in this talk so as a
reminder
our first example was loan screening in
that case the performance metric was
cost to the bank which is weighted sum
of false positives and false negatives
besides this performance metric we're
also looking at fairness and we were
evaluating fairness using these
aggregated metrics
and then these were quantifying the the
harms and benefits of each group
in terms of false positive rate for each
group and false negative rate
for each group our second scenario
was was speech to text
transcription system and in this case
our performance metric
was the word error rate and again in
order to evaluate fairness we're looking
at the disaggregated metrics
that were measuring word error rate for
each of the groups
now with these basic definitions in
place
i can tell you what are the kind of
uh who are the formulations that are
being solved by the reduction approach
for loan screening we would perhaps be
trying
minimizing the overall cost function
while
making sure that the difference between
the largest false positive rate across
groups and the smallest positive false
positive across groups
is is at most 0.05 in other words
we are making sure that the that the
difference between
the the worst and the best value of the
metric and in this case false positive
rate
is no more than 0.05 and similarly fall
for false negative rate
instead of looking at the difference we
could of course try
to bound the ratio and again between the
in this case between the smallest and
the largest false positive rate
and remember in this case closer to one
we get
the the better and in particular
so we might be we might be asking to
to ensure that this ratio is at least
0.90
in the speech to text transcription we
would be
looking to minimize the overall word
error rate while making sure that
each group gets get certain sufficient
uh quality of service and in this case
we would
for example say that none of the groups
experience more than 0.20
word error rate okay so these are some
of the examples
and in particular one thing to notice is
that here
we do get to control the amount of
violation and this is something that
will allow us to control the trade-offs
between objective and like the
constrained satisfaction
so let me summarize the advantages of
the reductions that they kind of reflect
some of the disadvantages that i
mentioned earlier the first one
is that i mentioned earlier already is
is that
the models that are produced by the
reductions approach do not need access
to the sensitive feature
at test time also because
by their design that they they work for
a much wider range of machine learning
tasks
for example so they're not limited to
binary classification for example they
might work for structure prediction
and as well as regression and they also
allow a wider range of fairness metrics
they also allow extracting the full
fairness performance frontier and this
is exactly because of what i would have
mentioned on the previous slide
but by allowing to set the different
levels uh different
on on what is the amount let's say
difference or ratio
that is allowed the main disadvantage
of of reductions approach is that they
actually require
re-running the algorithm on on the
on the whole data set and so and so that
they might be computational more
prohibited depending on on your setting
so what have we learned in this part of
the talk
so first i i've talked about fairness
assessment
now there are three components so there
are three steps
the first step is to identify the harms
or
benefits that come about as a result of
a given ai system
and that the two different ways how uh
how we've thought about them
is uh through adverse events just
quantifying how often this might occur
uh things like false positive rate and
false negative rate
are our metrics that quantify these but
we can also be directly measuring the
quality of service
for example using word error rate
um then the second step is to identify
the affected groups and when it comes to
affected groups
we were looking at various demographic
factors
but then in particular in quality of
service settings
there will often be some service
specific groups that
are associated with the kinds of surveys
or the kinds of
applications that we're in and besides
that we always need to be
careful to also consider the
intersections of these factors
and finally the third step is to define
the fairness metrics that are
appropriate for our domain
and the the workhorse of fairness
metrics are the desegregated metrics
that we can that we can summarize by
looking at the difference between the
best and the worst
the ratio between worst
and the best between the smallest and
largest typically
or the worst case performance across all
groups
after talking about assessment we looked
at two different
algorithmic mitigation techniques
post-processing which
is tailored to binary classification
and requires access to sensitive
features at the deployment time
and then reductions approach which is
more general
so let me uh let me stress a couple of
caveats that
uh that hannah mentioned at the
beginning of her talk uh
first and uh really uh while and i can't
stress this enough
is that that even though i did a quite a
deep dive into various technical
uh facets of fairness the in order to to
mitigate unfairness
we need to think about it um as a
socio-technical problem
in particular it's not enough to carry
out
some of this technical interventions
that i was talking about it is also
really important to consider the context
of of use of our algorithm
it is important to pay attention to task
definition perhaps
some of the tasks should not be
delegated to to artificial intelligence
at all
and when we are looking at assessment or
even mitigation
we should be we should be careful uh to
to consider a variety of data set
characteristics
the the second caveat that i would like
to bring up and that that i also brought
up a little bit earlier in the talk
is is that that fairness is this thing
but intertwined
with this various concepts in
anti-discrimination law
in particular with the concept
of dispatch treatment but
with that said is when you're thinking
about the fairness tooling it is
definitely no substitute for
working with legal professionals and in
some sense as as a business you might
think about
risk associated with uh with unfairness
as a separate kind of complementary uh
to to the list
risks associated with the discrimination
now let me wrap up by by giving you a
couple of additional pointers in case
you would like to dig
deeper so first off as i mentioned i'm
one of the
the co-creators and currently
maintainers of the open source
python toolkit called fairlearn so i
encourage you to go and
visit our website the disaggregated
metrics as well as post-processing and
reductions
are all implemented in our package uh if
you would like to dig
deeper into our uh into the example that
i was talking about earlier which is uh
the one about landing
you can check out the the white paper
that
the fairlearn team put together uh with
uh with ui
and of course uh if you would like to um
to to contribute and you can join the
fairlearn community we have we have
weekly calls there there is variety of
different ways uh
how to engage with us and uh one thing
that i'll just kind of mention is also
that
in this talk there is there's three
different
additional pages of resources that you
will be able to to
access if you download the slides which
are available for you as well
now with that i would like to thank you
for your attention and please uh
stay tuned for the q a session right
after
this talk ends
hey everyone thank you for attending our
webinar on
fairness related harms and ai systems
and for attending the live q a portion
as well
so i am hannah wallach and i've got mira
dudek here as well
and over the next few minutes we are
going to answer some of the amazing
questions submitted by you
the audience so with that i'm just going
to go ahead and get started what i want
to do
is actually start by tackling a couple
of the questions really
bigger picture questions that were asked
early on in the webinar
that i did answer in text but i think
they're just really really important so
i also wanted to cover them here as well
so the first one of these is how can the
incentives of corporations be reconciled
with notions of ethics and fairness
and are internal corporate researchers
well placed to ask
awkward ethical questions and i think
this question is just so
fundamentally important to this
landscape particularly for those of us
who are working in industry
so i just wanted to answer it here on
the call um the first thing i want to
say is that obviously the answer is
definitely going to depend on the
corporation
different companies are different and so
these things will vary
but at the end of the day most companies
really don't want to release
products or services that for example
perform worse for some group of people
than they do for others so that exhibit
quality of service harms and there are
many reasons why they don't want to do
this
ranging from the fact that they might
miss out on some segment of potential
customers if their system
underperforms for those group of people
um also this can lead to really bad pr
as well so there's a number of different
reasons why
why actually even there making sure that
systems don't have performance
disparities
is something that corporations want to
do i also want to know
that most corporations don't want to
release systems that engage in
active stereotyping of people or
demeaning people
at the end of the day this isn't really
desirable behavior
and so even there as well mitigating
fairness related harms
is definitely something that many
corporations want to do
and then as for the second part of the
question personally
i think it's super important that we
have people working both within
and outside of companies asking awkward
questions no matter where they're placed
and again people's abilities to ask
awkward questions is going to be is
going to vary
depending on the particular company but
i think it's critical if we want to
collectively affect change
we really need different people in
different positions who are therefore
differently
able to sort of tackle aspects of
affecting change
working together if we want to move the
needle on this
so again it depends on the company but i
do think that in many companies
researchers
are able to ask really difficult
questions and through that process of
asking difficult
questions are then able to affect change
that they perhaps wouldn't be able to do
if they were asking those questions
outside of the company
i also want to take one more question
here before i hand over
to miro to take a question so this one i
liked a lot because it just really
highlighted some of the challenges
involved in developing technology that
is is
perceived as fair so here the question
is
for search ai does the existence of
philosophical discussions
influence the results that are returned
so for example does the discussion
around
under representation of women in
executive roles
affect the search results and i really
like this question because it gets at
the question of
what do we want our ai systems to do so
before you even build a system
what is it that you want that system to
do and how are you going to make that
happen
and in particular when we're thinking
about search engines or other
other systems that sort of represent the
world in different ways
the most natural question to us is do we
want our systems to represent the world
as it is
which may be full of societal biases and
unfairness and stuff like that
or do we want our ai systems to
represent the world as we want it to be
so more of that sort of aspirational
view
so and then if we take that latter
perspective so let's say we
do we do say that we want our systems to
reflect the world as we want it to be
well whose aspirational goal should we
be prioritizing
these are really tough questions and
there are no universal answers
and they're absolutely questions that
people working on search engines have to
grapple with and have grappled with for
decades
and i want to note though that these are
questions that they grapple with even
outside the context of fairness
so i just wanted to highlight that
because i think it's just a really
great example of how there are no easy
answers here
and whenever we're developing
technologies we've really really got to
think through
some of these sort of challenging
challenging questions
all right so now i will hand over to
miro nero do you want to answer a couple
questions
um yes thanks all again for sending all
of the fantastic questions
what i'm going to do i'm going to answer
a couple of questions
that have not been answered yet so uh
the first question that i'm going to
pick
is uh um has been submitted
by simon stumpf
i think the name and the question is how
how do you deal with issues of no
objective ground truth
for example in loan applications we
don't really know whether a person would
have defaulted on the loan
we only have the decision of a loan
officer okay
so if i if i understand this question
correctly is
that is that we only collect the data on
who defaults or who did not default
among the slice of population that was
given the loan in the first place
and this is something that i also
alluded to in the talk
and in this specific setting we actually
have a variety of counterfactual
modeling techniques
so so to the extent that we can model
any any past decision making
using uh say propensity scores uh we can
then then re-weight
our data to at least compensate for some
of it the catch here is
that that of course these propensity
scores are driven by our assumptions
but but in a way like the best we can do
to deal with this kind of censoring
in the data that occurs is try to
account for it statistically
now now this gives us an idea about
about this kind of counterfactual
questions but uh
but because it was based on the model
it's really really important
in in in settings like this then to
continue monitoring
the system once it's deployed and once a
new system kicks in
is it is it actually performing as as we
were
estimating it would i'm going to take
another question
that was asked from
from university of washington and here
the question is
whether the reductions approach can be
used for tree based models like grano
forests
or decision trees and the reduction
approach as i mentioned as the name says
what it does
it takes some standard supervised
learning
approach and then effectively will act
as a wrapper
so so so the answer is yes so as long as
you have an algorithm
that can optimize classification error
or some other loss function
and and it's by returning decision trees
that are optimal for uh
for that loss function then then we can
absolutely
use it in our reductions in fact our api
is set up
really to just kind of accept and any
object
that can that can that can that takes a
training data weighty training data as
an input
and returns any binary classifiers and
outputs so so the answer to this
question is yes
and i do have any more questions
yeah so there's one here that i really
liked which i i didn't get
a chance to answer um via via text and
so i just wanted to bring it up here
and the question is will harms naturally
be mitigated as we capture more
diverse kinds of training data and i
like this question because at first at
sort of first blush the answer might be
yes
you know many fairness-related harms are
caused
by a lack of data about some particular
segment of the population
but here's the thing as i said in the
first bit of the talk
that is one reason why systems can
behave unfairly
but there are other reasons too so one
of the other reasons might be model
structures that are too simple to
capture the diversity of the real world
and so in that kind of a scenario almost
no matter how much more diverse training
data you capture
or diverse data you capture you may end
up in a scenario
where your model just can't support it
so the system is still
unfair even though you have more diverse
data
so that would be an example where no
capturing more diverse kinds of training
data doesn't help
or as another example if the content of
the data is problematic
let's say if we are if we are dealing
with a scenario where we're modeling
natural language
and so we are we are sort of you know
using data obtained by people
and sort of what they say in society of
course
capturing more diverse kinds of training
data will be helpful
but it still won't necessarily mitigate
the fact that
people people use language to express
societal biases and to
express their views their values of
their opinions and their judgments
and so it's very difficult to to deal
with all of that
simply by collecting more data so that's
another scenario where
where where it might not be as simple as
just sort of collecting more data
if we want to mitigate fairness related
harms
all right um okay
back over to you miro so
let me maybe try to answer one
more question uh which is um
so far during the talk uh we saw that
fairness was used in controlling
the harm seen various categorizations of
a given population
by age render religion etc can fairness
by which i mean the i'm assuming
mitigation techniques and assessment
techniques be applied beyond
that application what are other
applications when
fairness does not necessarily involve
human characteristics
and um i think that um that there
are many applications where where where
we we
where we are aware where this was not
necessarily based on human
characteristics one way uh one uh
version what i'm familiar with is is
imagine that
uh that you're i mean your software
company that is maybe rolling out a new
version of an
app and and you want that you would like
to make sure
is that the the bugs across variety of
platforms
get caught up earlier in the process in
this case your category
categories mic might correspond to
different kinds of devices
or different kinds of regions different
kinds of
different kinds of settings that the
users might have
so so in this case you know you want to
make sure that that
the in this case the sound the adverse
events might be a bad experience but
better upgraded experience um but then
there is also
a long-term benefit out of out of the
upgrade
experience for the whole population to
be good and so so this is one example
where uh
where you can include categories that go
be beyond just some of these demographic
characteristics
that we had and i think
we we might have time maybe for one more
question
hannah do you see any any question that
you'd like to
maybe i do there's one more that i want
to pick here
again this is one that that i did
actually answered during
um the the uh written part of the
of the q a but i still think it's it's
one that's particularly
interesting to me so i want to highlight
it here and that question is what
recommendations do you have
for defining fairness metrics for types
of harms that are less easily quantified
and i like this question a lot because
it gets at a number of different things
that i'm really interested in
as a researcher so the first way i want
to answer that and i should say this is
an active area of research not just for
me
but for many researchers working in this
kind of an area
and so there aren't super easy answers
here yet
but there are a couple things i want to
flag so the first thing
is that it is possible to get some sense
of whether these things are taking place
even without metrics to to quantify them
so you can look at systems you can
engage with systems by perhaps
undertaking red teaming so having people
do red teaming
where they try and actually sort of get
the system to behave in problematic ways
to see if this might happen and this
isn't going to give you some sort of
single number quantified metric
but it will give you information as to
whether some of these
less less quantifiable fairness related
harms
might be happening another example is
actually to do
sort of user testing and to to get
feedback from users and other
stakeholders
about their experiences and perceptions
with systems
either before or after deployment again
to get some kind of information about
whether there might be fairness related
harms
that perhaps aren't easily quantified
and then the third thing that i want to
flag
is that if you're trying to perhaps
define a quantitative metric
for some of these these types of harms
that are often less easily quantified
then i want to just recommend using the
framework of measurement modeling from
the quantitative social sciences
so i mentioned actually during my
portion of the webinar that i had a
paper at the facts conference earlier
this week
on measurement modeling and fairness and
i bring this up because this framework
can be super useful
for making sure that any assumptions
that you're making when you're defining
a metric
are explicitly stated and that those
assumptions have then been sufficiently
well
well validated before you go ahead and
use that metric
so i just wanted to flag that one as
well
okay all right nero do you want to
wrap things up yes i think so
thanks uh again everybody for for
attending today
as well as those you know that my here
in recording in the future for
for tuning in and thanks for all the
attendees for their fantastic
questions we didn't quite get to answer
all of them but i hope we
answered um quite a few that you were
interested in
and please make sure to check out the
resources tab
the one if you want to dig deeper in
particular the
the pdf of the presentation does
include the
like a lot of references and pointers to
to literature
that that will be a great starting point
if you want to
hear more thanks again and have a great
day